[Music]
how many how many of you are are
familiar with the little caesar's hot
and ready pizza yeah that's the five
dollar one it's quite it's quite good
for five dollars pizza
yeah
you can get it in cheese or pepperoni
unfortunately because of inflation
it now costs eleven percent more
oh
it's like five dollars 55 cents that's
tight that's even cooler sounding it
doesn't matter it's no longer just five
dollars it's 555 yes plus tax [ __ ] but
what if they make a six dollar bill
would you get mad excuse me the
convenience of a five dollar pizza is
like here's a five buddy right but now
you gotta go two bills right but if they
make a six dollar bill then you just go
here you go buddy back to the old days
even when it was a five dollar piece you
still had to pay [ __ ] delivery and
tax and everything like that yeah you
get the [ __ ]
no
he just hit him
he hadn't been walked out of there
that's the real question
all right fine [ __ ] there's still
time oh yeah vegas guys
no one's saying nothing dude
yeah it was ten percent you guys googled
it earlier i watched a video on how uh
little caesars can
you know live like
go on for so long and cheap so i mean
peso [ __ ] charge sold goddamn little
cat get my goddamn words out of my
[ __ ] mouth all right
oh yeah yeah that's the right pocket
because this wouldn't have worked
well no wait that's how he that's how we
talk he's the one that stutters
trump is trump can't answer questions
he's oh yeah he's going to fix it i'm
trying to fix it
very affordable very very real
very affordable we did a good job good
job do you know why little savers can
spend such little money right it's
because they're a delivery company
that's first and foremost they um
they're a big distribution company
and they're like fedex basically they
they their produce distribution mm-hmm
other people pay for the cost of all of
their warehousing all that [ __ ]
and then they're able to set up these
little caesars on their routes wow and
so since everyone else is that's so
smart yo that's a smart businessman yeah
so that's why they they can charge it so
cheap
i had no idea yeah wow yeah so if
they're like delivering supplies for
like let's say domino's or pizza hut or
like whatever company right on the way
to their routes they just drop off their
pizzas or whatever they have warehousing
and let's say like 80 of that is covered
by them they have a free like rent area
to cover their pizzas you know so that's
crazy
wow you know they eat the cost and then
they can just flip it makes me feel
better about it because i thought it was
because something was wrong with the
pizza yeah i always thought there was
something but now it's like there's
something right with the business model
yeah
they made it work for itself i have to
say too i i you know when you're growing
up you don't know you're in a white
trash family you just think that you're
just in a regular family yeah and then
that every family has this [ __ ]
trailer parked in the front of their
yard and that every family just has a
bunch of trash in their backyard like
literally just old cars and stuff i
thought my white trash friends were
actually very wealthy because they had
so many cars that weren't working but it
was a lot of cars that their dad was
working on so i was like man my dad only
has one car but your dad has 20 in the
backyard they're working on them by
drinking beer and yelling at the wife
yeah and growing up i always thought
like man hoas suck because my parents
always hate hoas and then i realized
that like oh no
my parents say hoas because all our
neighbors hate us because we have a
junkyard in our backyard and it's
ruining their property value
and that sucks for our neighbors big
time
um so yeah when i was growing up eating
little caesars i was like this is the
best pizza on the [ __ ] planet earth i
thought my uh white trash friends were
so rich because for us fast food was
like a special event going to mcdonald's
or whatever yeah but they always had
fast food so i was like man you guys get
the [ __ ] good [ __ ] yeah you guys get
to eat out every day yeah i was like you
guys get the [ __ ] whoa you're rich i
still feel that way
fast food every day i can only eat
mcdonald's once a week yeah my mom's
like cooking me dogs like bell peppers
mcdonald's hundred percent true like
every other friday my parents every
other poor summer this morning is when i
went to go get mcdonald's last my
parents were like um
you know
always
dealing with debt stuff right big time
yeah and so yeah we would get we would
get little caesars and it would be like
whoa this is a [ __ ] delicacy and [ __ ]
but knowing that
the hot and ready pizza is now
no longer just five dollars so when they
put on the box
it kind of there's something to me that
kind of does it feel like you're being
ripped off a little bit you know they're
not very accessible are they no and it's
like one dollar for crazy bread too so
it's like it's getting up there now i
bet you if you could purchase it with
usc you'd be fine you got him right away
it's the us dollar part that's messed up
when you think um
crypto adoption is gonna be to that
point where we can actually just buy
whatever with different coins probably
this year right isn't it getting close
yeah it's it's i mean you know alice is
about to happen which is uh well there's
another one too um but the idea
basically you're about to get a card
that allows you to to transact with
crypto at vendors so merchants won't
even know that you're that they're
receiving crypto because it does the
swaps in the background on the
blockchain
and it pays them out it settles in real
currency for them wow yeah
so i think it's going to be really
really soon i hope so it's just hard
though because like us regulation is
like really intense right like so many
of these protocols and these programs
and these cards and partnerships with
mastercard visa they work in like every
other country
you can literally just like
i don't know why maybe other countries
like now we don't need your tax because
you earned it yourself and they're
idealists i don't know but well joe was
saying this for two years he's like if
you live in the uk you have more
economic freedom in the united states
and i didn't know what he meant our
propaganda makes it seem like the uk is
more socialist and this and that and
then like how do they have more economic
freedom there's actually a a a a
a nonprofit organization or whatever who
creates like a like a graph of like the
world's economic freedom list right it's
like a top 100 list and it shows um
basically from like one to least free on
a whole number of criterias so like how
business friendly is it like is it easy
to open up um how about like you know
paying your employees or like the cost
of doing business how much government
control whatever whatever and it's based
off of a criteria of like
um how difficult
it is
to open up a business and and uh be
economic free you know so like
like countries that are more corrupt
where the government will come and steal
your [ __ ] that's considered the the last
of the list yeah
oh you found it
holy [ __ ] yeah so if you see the list
there
um oh uk's number seven yeah it's pretty
high up we're number 20. number 20. and
then it's weird because when you're in
america you think land of the free
business friendly this is the land of
entrepreneurship and whatever and then
it comes to find out that we're not as
free as what we thought we were because
we always make fun of europeans like oh
you're so communist but look at that
yeah it's like actually no yeah yeah and
singapore is who does you know tarot
cards and all that kind of stuff so yeah
and then you know what's weird too is uh
uh you know we're under the belief that
china is this [ __ ] controlling
communist country which is not far from
the truth but they're advancing further
than the us is in sustainable energy and
[ __ ] it cannot like it's great like
they ban ban bitcoin but then they're
all cashless as in like and they're one
of the biggest holders of it too yeah
well they're number 107.
i don't know what that means
but yeah no i mean
like you're talking about there's just
they're not economic free that was i
went off on a tangent but i'm just
saying that they're more advanced and
things that we
wouldn't have thought of like being um
environmentally friendly and and trying
to do things that sustainable energy
where we're we're we have a fossil fuel
kind of sustain like uh fossil fuel
but aren't they huge polluters like huge
huge yeah i think that might be a more
recent thing that they're more
active in that scene but i think yeah i
think that um
so they were definitely
learn from their mistakes faster
yeah because they got days where they
like hey nobody drive for like two days
and like it's like it's like your
license plate sometimes when the small
gets out of control the government will
issue like hey if your license plate
ends with this you can't drive for this
period of time oh wow it'll actually
clear up right this guy's it will it
will that's crazy yeah but i mean that
was also i think during much more of a
time where like um they introduced a lot
more capitalistic like views and
priorities into their nation um and like
the you know one child rule stuff like
that started to evolve and change so i
think they began developing at a really
really rapid rate in like the recent
decades and whatnot but definitely uh
from that chart standpoint i can
understand why from an economic freedom
concept they might be like lower on the
list but i do agree with joe there there
are way faster pace when it comes to a
lot of other things yeah yeah i i i went
off on a tangent and i didn't want to
mix the two economic freedom-wise
america is still higher on the less
because china what they do is they could
come in and just take a company right
you know so economically free no but
then like uh the point was there's a lot
of propaganda that we get in the u.s and
we have beliefs about other countries
that might not be true you know and it
might be outdated our propaganda yeah
hey dude venezuela i've i've only heard
that they're starving and then they
[ __ ] up because they're socialists as
[ __ ] but if reporters on the ground
there people who go there who aren't
owned by all these companies who want
you to think that they'll show you fully
stocked grocery stores and all this
stuff really like they're vlogging out
there yeah they're showing you they're
like they'll actually go inside of these
stores and show you what's actually
going on same uh journalists from north
korea state controlled stay controlled
no these are these are like these are
like guys from i don't know if you guys
know the gray zone or any of those guys
but they're they do independent
journalism not funded by
ngo or not funded by by government
organizations or
they um they
they do seed funds from private people
and stuff and i i'm i'm a fan so yeah
it's good to hear news that's not just
what the state-owned groups say i do see
a shift though of like
a lot of people waking up to
it's funny using the word awaken well
but then like a lot of people are
questioning their own governments and
this is happening worldwide i wish it
happened everywhere right i do but it's
weird to me because i've been [ __ ]
waist deep in this [ __ ] since high
school right so that's like [ __ ] what
1999
and then
i've been kind of saying this but
because i am such a weird person like to
begin with people write me off like a
[ __ ] and we've been talking
about this for some time on jk news
right and then just recently people are
like oh my god there they go again with
that [ __ ] conspiracy like we did
about inflation and how people who are
asset rich are about to kill it yeah
during the pandemic i mean it's it's the
same [ __ ] as ever was i know and what's
what blows my mind is that now even
questioning the narrative of what's
popular is considered fringe thinking or
conspiracy but i think isn't that what
you're supposed to do in a democracy is
questioned like the whole vaccine thing
right if you question it you're an
anti-vaxxer and all of a sudden you
don't believe in science but i'm like
they're silencing scientists it's crazy
when
people are vaccinated
that question the vaccine and they're
still labeled anti-vaxxer exactly
i'm vaccinated they've been vaccinated
already they're just saying shouldn't it
be a choice and like anti-vaxxer i'm
like what the [ __ ] that's crazy yeah but
that's how simplistic you can get if you
let it right crazy like i can't believe
because it makes people feel comfortable
right because it's like if you don't
have the the critical thinking skill
because it's a skill to be able to think
and to
seek out other information that's
opposing your viewpoint and if you don't
have those skills then it's never going
to happen so it's easier for people to
be like ah you don't know what you're
talking about you're crazy like you
don't you you're thinking fringe you
know you're [ __ ] insane it's weird to
be mad at someone for questioning but
not be mad
at someone who doesn't have a good
enough answer yeah hmm so true
i mean or they change their answer every
two months which i like yeah i'm like
why isn't that maddening yeah what blows
my mind is
why is it
crazy to believe
that large institutions
have other agendas beyond our well-being
what agenda joe what kind of conspiracy
[ __ ] is this like do you think the world
runs on honor yes and
caring of others like
by profit is that what you're saying
yeah it's like no no the government
isn't ever [ __ ] going to be tainted
by money it's ran by the most part well
that's never happened before i mean look
at cigarettes i know it's like doctors
used to endorse cigarettes yeah and
there you know if you believed in
science back then and if you never
question the science if a doctor is
telling you smoking a cigarette every
day is healthy or taking a
pharmaceutical right or or if they're if
pfizer is sponsoring every [ __ ]
single news company
you know
if you question the vaccine you're still
a [ __ ] anti-vaxxer it's wild out
there it is [ __ ] crazy well that's it
i love pfizer i know
jk news we're ready to get sponsored
you